while it brought us classics like
Seinfeld and Friends the 90s brought us
a number of less than spectacular
sitcoms if you're old now perhaps you
saw some of them when they aired from
quickly canceled mistakes - regrettably
long-running disaster pieces here on the
90s sitcoms that just didn't age well my
two dads barely made the cutoff for the
90s with a third and final episode that
aired in the first spring of the decade
and back then the premise probably
seemed like enough of a novelty to sell
the entire show you know how a lot of
kids are raised by their dad and their
mom well how hard would it blow your
mind if you saw a young woman who was
raised by a dad and a second dad what
it's official with parents unless you're
a time traveler from the late 80s the
idea of someone being raised by two men
probably as you wondering if you miss
the twist that would make this setup
interesting there were after all plenty
of reasons for that to happen
even back then let alone today these
days most media has gotten better at
depicting the reality of families that
don't fit into that allegedly
traditional mold that we've seen on
everything from Leave It to Beaver to
The Simpsons
that's the wacky twist on display here
though - guys raise a kid high jinks
ensue to be fair the actual details of
the premise are a whole lot weirder for
one thing both of these dudes hate each
other as they once dated the same woman
neither of them even know they have a
daughter until a judge shows up with a
court order that forces them into
co-parenting and what definitely seems
like some actionable judicial overreach
also one of them is a free-spirited
artist and the other is an uptight
businessmen what an original concept
really though if you tried to run this
past the test audience today they'd be
left wondering why the two dads weren't
in a relationship with one another when
you get right down to it the weirdest
thing about dinosaurs was that it
managed to run for a full four seasons
with a premise of it's a regular sitcom
but instead of humans it's dinosaurs and
elaborate costumes operated by multiple
puppeteers seriously everything in the
show is exactly like contemporary life
in the early 90s without even having the
veneer of Stone Age sight gags that you
get on the Flintstones their TV isn't a
Paleolithic bird drawing pictures as
fast as it can it's just you know a TV
to be fair dinosaurs was pretty poor
were thinking for its time partly
because it was a pet project that Jim
Henson had been worth
before his death in 1990 most of the
episodes made a solid attempt at social
satire taking on topics like religious
extremism and corporate greed
unfortunately most satire ages about as
well as a fresh avocado and today's
audiences are far more likely to see the
shows attempts at dealing with social
issues as toothless just take the
episode about gender roles that boils
down to manner acting like women women
are acting like men isn't this hilarious
or worse the episodes that are downright
inappropriate like the episode where
Monica is harassed at work by a
character who is literally named sexual
hereis a trial is called to try to
figure out what wait for it sexual
Harris meant if that isn't the worst pun
of the 90s we shudder to think what is
out of date jokes aside there's also the
issue of dinosaurs absolutely bonkers nd
after four seasons the entire cast even
the baby are explicitly doomed to a slow
death by freezing and starvation as well
as the extinction of their entire
species it might be a nod to the
apocalypse that killed Earth's real
dinosaurs but it's hard to imagine
modern audiences thinking that's a good
way to finish off your series then again
if you're watching a show about
dinosaurs you've got to be prepared to
see that and coming after the Simpsons
became a cultural phenomenon Fox's
competitor networks tried to jump on the
trend by making their own adult-oriented
animated shows unfortunately they forgot
to make them good leading to a brief
explosion of primetime cartoons so bad
that they make the Simpsons season 26
look like the Simpsons season or the
weirdest one of the bunch was Capitol
critters a cartoon about all those rats
in Washington DC you know Congress
singing it but seriously it was about
actual rats and mice who live in the
White House and are menaced by cats
drawn as caricatures of George HW Bush
and Dan Quayle it's sort of like if you
combine the West Wing with an American
tale and then made the resulting chimera
drink rain alcohol until it couldn't see
straight to be fair the premise isn't
inherently terrible even if it would
probably be better suited for a
newspaper comic strip than a TV show
doomed to fail after a single season the
real problem here is that the episodes
themselves were way darker than
audiences at the time
or today for that matter might expect
this is a series that started with an
episode where a simple country mouse has
to move to Washington after witnessing
the graphic on-screen murders of his
family by exterminators including a
sequence where he tries to tear a great
out of a wall to free his mother as
she's being gassed to death two episodes
later the story is about the mice
getting a gun like an actual human sized
revolver so that they can murder a cat
who killed one of their friends in the
episodes opening moments it out really
truck with the idea that today's
generation is oversensitive or easily
upset but if audiences in 1992 rejected
this thing there's no way an audience in
2020 would want to deal with it we've
got our own problems thank you family
dog was created by Brad Bird who would
go on to direct animated classics like
The Iron Giant and The Incredibles the
show got its start as an episode of the
anthology series amazing stories which
was produced by Steven Spielberg and
featured designs from Tim Burton in
other words that's a pedigree that on
paper should lead to a mind-blowing
underrated classic of animation
unfortunately family dog is both
miserable and shockingly uninspired for
evidence of the latter look no further
than the fact that there are two
different episodes based around Jonah
the title pup having to deal with larger
meaner dogs owned by two different sets
of neighbors recycling a plot is one
thing when you've got a long-running
series but family dog clocked in at just
10 episodes one of which was a rerun of
The Amazing Stories segment even that
might be forgivable that the series had
any of the charm that bird would show on
his later work Jonah's family is made up
of a bunch of idiotic church so
unlikable that even the most jaded
viewer would be left asking themselves
do these people have any redeeming
qualities
it was justifiably short-lived in 1993
but one has to imagine that it would
bear even worse today modern viewers
have enjoyed not only 30 years of The
Simpsons but also 20 years of Adult Swim
redefining what grown-up animated shows
can be especially ones focused on
characters that viewers find it hard to
like this thing would be laughed out of
the room by the creators of Squidbillies
but really that would be for the best if
it hadn't bird might never have gotten
to work on that movie about the big
robot that wants to be Superman
released in 1997 over-the-top sadly
isn't about a trucker who somehow has to
win both an 18-wheeler and custody of
his estranged son in an arm wrestling
tournament instead it's a show about an
out-of-work actor whose career was gone
so sour and he has to move into a hotel
full of wacky characters run by the
woman he was once married to for 12 days
intrigued probably not since it's a
pretty generic premise but take a look
at this cast Tim Curry stars as the
actor annie potts is the ex-wife and
steve carell is one of those wacky
characters appearing as a chef named
your go by all rights this series had
the combined comedic power of
Ghostbusters the office and clue and
that should be enough to elevate even
the worst premise into something worth
watching do not under any circumstances
be fooled into checking it out
curry pots and Carell are all phenomenal
talents in their own right but over the
top brought down such a way to crushing
mediocrity upon them that they never had
a chance it was canceled after three
episodes and while its bizarrely
star-studded status has earned it some
interest to be a bootlegs it's just not
worth watching it's only made worse
today by the fact that all two of those
actors already had a respectable career
under their belts the third has gone on
to become a sitcom icon it's pretty good
son cookie Steve Carell did manage to
bring some comedy out of it eventually
though at more than one awards show he's
read a review of over the top that goes
I have stood in a freezer full of dead
people at the morgue
I've seen a man's scalp pulled back over
his nose but I can now honestly say that
until Steve Carell's turned in the
premiere of over-the-top I have never
known true horror from the United States
founding through the Civil War and
reconstruction America's history of
slavery has been a terrible stain on the
nation and certainly not something to
joke about and yet somehow against all
odds the secret diary of Desmond Piper
exists once having been greenlit on
basic cable at least it didn't last for
long
it disappeared after just four weeks
back in October 1998 on UPN a network
that apparently figured if nobody was
watching anyway they might as well do
whatever they wanted in this case
anything was a sitcom about Desmond
Piper played by chai McBride and a role
that could best be described this
Piper is an English expatriates and con
artist who came to America and got a job
as Abraham Lincoln's valet during the
Civil War unsurprisingly this premise
didn't work at all the jokes were built
around Lincoln as a poor henpecked
husband to a shrewish Mary Todd Union
General Ulysses s Grant's alcoholism and
how well-endowed Confederate general
Stonewall Jackson was the show started
with an episode about Abraham Lincoln
sexting via telegram memorably titled
AOL Abe online and that's a joke that
holds up best play I can't believe the
war is the easy part of my day
needless to say fibers brief tenure on
UPN was heralded by protests from the
n-double-a-cp and the ire of critics who
were left and disgusted disbelief by
some of the jokes in the pilot those
included Desmond narrowly escaping being
hanged a minstrel show number and a joke
about how Desmond should get his feet
off the table because quote the slaves
haven't been emancipated yet when that
got out UPN switched up the episode
order and went with a slightly less
offensive episode which the Washington
Post called quote controversial and
asinine and about as funny as getting
your teeth cleaned on the bright side
they did say that it quotes was not so
much racist as it was stupid so that's a
plus relatively speaking the years since
haven't done fight for any favors if
anything it seems like a worse idea now
than it did then which is saying
something these days the show's lasting
legacy is that it was mentioned as the
favorite show of the characters on
clerks the animated series and really
when your lasting legacy is being dunked
on by another show that only lasted six
episodes something definitely went wrong
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
television history are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]